the Joe Rogan experience I almost bought
a dog Oh Argentina and the guy was like
right before I bought it he was like hey
you're gonna have this dog in bed with
you and I go yeah of course he goes I'm
not selling it to you mommy really yeah
because you got it there's certain dogs
where you have to become the master like
like dog origin Tino's are like bull
Mastiffs but pit bulls among steroids
yeah and the guy was like yeah man if it
once it gets in bed with you you've lost
the house good call man thank you for
stopping [ __ ] my wife oh my god
imagine he starts growling you while
he's humping your wife's leg oh no what
have I done I let this giant beast get
too comfortable in my house [ __ ] your
wife look at that thing that's the most
beautiful dog I've ever seen in my life
it looks like it the clown if it was an
evil dog it does look like it does go
back to that picture it looks like it
looks like that's one that's Pennywise
the clown oh [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] Pennywise I'm so glad I
didn't get one now doesn't it look at
that [ __ ] dog oh my god the muscle
and thing of preposterous when was the
last time you got attacked by a dog I've
never been attacked by a dog oh Jesus
that's that looks like the rock if it
was a dog Jesus Christ and that's 130
pounds that's a girl - that's a female
dog try to try to grab on to any part of
that dog to stop it from killing you
good luck there's not one part of you
that looks like a demon like a
sweet-faced demon you got wandering
around your yard looking to kill
burglars that's the dog I wanted whoo
build on that [ __ ] Jesus Christ
okay that's that is a crazy dog to have
around your house like you got to really
be on top of things
look at that head with the collar look
at that one in the middle
oh my God look at Shaw
god damn it dicks almost hard that dog
so ready God bro
that's a polar bear that's like having a
polar bear how is that any different
how's it any different those those and
Connie Corsos are [ __ ] that's the
[ __ ] with dogs yeah
if my wife leaves me I'm moving to
Malibu I'm getting that Connie course
one a den at dog origin Tino yeah those
[ __ ] oh look at the [ __ ] muscles
in the chat for that thing come on man
that's just too weird
if I feel like you have a dog like that
also it's like you have this obligation
to work that [ __ ] out every day
every day that isn't you have a super
athlete you just can't have that thing
in your yard being bored like that's a
different kind of dog that's why that's
why he was like you're not letting in
bed with you I was like of course yeah
why running [ __ ] son you got to keep
those [ __ ] on a leash and train
them well from the time they're really
young or or get one that's trained but
even then I what I've heard about like
Belgium alum was in particularly like
you got to be the boss like that thing
has to respect the years that was is
that what Cal or a shop got I wouldn't
listen to his wife at all it was like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] and she's like oh no I
got those crazy dog in my house it's not
listening today yeah but if a dog thinks
you're not the boss then it becomes the
boss like you decided Brendan was the
boss like leave this big [ __ ]
with a deep voice you know he's six foot
five or whatever he is
yeah and he's gigantic and so he's
around this dogs like hey bro I'm the
dogs like okay big guy
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you who you where's the big guy I
think I'm the big guy [ __ ]
[Applause]